dan I heard you retiring it's terrible
you gonna lose your last case Diane
Lockhart is back and better than ever on
the new spin-offs the good fight and
only et has the exclusive scoop straight
from star christine baranski
well someone had told you back when The
Good Wife 156 episodes ago started that
you would be playing Diane for this long
what would you say to them I probably
say if I'm lucky I will get to do Diane
that long she's such a wonderful
dignified intelligent powerful woman who
you know whether is the ups and downs
with terrific aplomb and grace how
wonderful to put that out in the world
and there are women like that fighting
the good fight still fighting the good
fight and thanks to CBS all access the
series is able to push past the
profanity boundaries that The Good Wife
was limited to on network TV I think
it's great yes I actually do under the
big f words several times but only alone
you know discreetly you know it and in a
ladylike way in a Diane kind of way but
yeah you get to let it rip a little I
always say it's like being unplugged
what about my my retirement money it's
uncle lastly is there anything that you
want to say out there to The Good Wife
fans who are gonna be tuning in
Oh Good Wife fans please stay with us
give us a chance I think you will be
delighted it's much of what you know and
much of what lies in store will be a
delightful surprise have fun with it and
do cbs.com you will you will find out
how to all access it it's easy you can
do all of those other Netflix shows you
know you can do this don't be
intimidated
[Music]
you